what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today the trailer for Guardians of the
Galaxy the holiday special John how are
you I'm feeling festive how are you sir
good with Halloween just around the
corner I'm in a very Christmassy mood
right now absolutely so many so many
things it's like they're trying to
overshadow some Black Adam Superman
thing going on right now no anywho guys
leave a merry merry like if you can be
very much appreciated anywho let's get
to it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the calendar that right now on Earth
it's almost Christmas time we don't have
time for trivialities like Christmas but
Peter's so sad about Gamora being gone
oh okay we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift it will make
him happy what the hell there we go oh
my
[Music]
something special he will never forget
oh and special
oh what oh my God I think I do for the
legendary Kevin
for the legendary Kevin Bacon yes what's
your voice is smaller I think maybe he
didn't hear you oh
Kevin Bacon
introducing
Footloose hero
and now we'll only be one degree
separate I think we're looking for a
celebrity that's like this murder was
gonna be coming back
that's a great great great great little
trailer now that does feel like a
genuine Christmas special it's nice to
get a to get one special presentation
that was a full-on horror film uh
contributing the 1940s you know black
and white horror films to get something
with characters that we already know
that we're already familiar with and
putting them into a different genre but
that feels fitting for the kind of
characters that they are it's James gun
so there's going to be a lot of music
infused in here I heard a rumor this is
just a rumor um that they would do
original Christmas songs in the Marvel
Spirit oh that'd be fun I don't know the
the details of what they're gonna do but
I like Christmas movie and then also of
course you know like this is supposed to
take place after Avengers end game
before Guardians 3 and is supposed to
sort of be this thing that fills in a
bit of a gap and also somehow ties a
little bit of a bow around phase four in
a way I don't exactly know what that
really fully means but this has that
good kind of Christmas spirit type of
movie Vibe where sometimes these
Christmas movies have that theme of
grieving you know it's the family and
the friends that uh remind us of the
things we love and help pull us together
and perhaps we'll explain how we got
Star-Lord back into a more positive
space that we see him in at the
beginning of Thor 11 Thunder because
even in Thor love and Thunders despite
whatever you think about that movie yeah
all right you know and it does start off
with uh the Guardians Star-Lord is
someone who is like I don't know if
tiger whitetida really thought about
this stuff but he is someone who is is
telling Thor about you know like I had a
hard time but it was these guys my
family though the ones that helped get
me through things and then perhaps this
is that story that they're going to tell
because he does look not out of Thor
love and thunder but plucked out of the
end of Avengers end game this does feel
like a real Christmas movie I feel like
Guardians exist as part of the family
genre as well as whatever sci-fi Opera
space thing they're trying to occupy as
well and so yeah that lens perfectly
toward Christmas our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ is going to make Peter
Quill feel all better but yeah yeah like
I like the idea of having a Marvel
special presentation that unlike
werewolf my knight which will factor
into other things it felt pretty
self-contained whereas this feels like
it's going to be yeah like you said a
piece of connective tissue in one way or
another and yeah that idea that your
family and the people that your chosen
family the people that you know you are
with and who know you the best you know
might be the ones to pull you out with
some kind of sentimental holiday gesture
is a nice way of doing a Christmas
special where the fact that it is a
holiday special is actually kind of
important and the fodder for you know
bits and fun you know it's one of those
things that looks like an actual story
like an actual movie but also you know
like a Christmas special so it doesn't
look quite as disconnected as maybe I
was expecting it to from the outset or
like you know a lot of people have
pointed to the Star Wars holiday special
which is a bit of a medley of things
this looks much more focused than that
which I appreciate two yeah they're
coming back to Earth they're going to
Hollywood they're probably going to be a
lot of fun Marvel gag characters on
Hollywood Boulevard and stuff like that
and if Kevin Bacon is here I can only
imagine that we'll get a couple other
fun and surprising appearances as well
Howard the Duck man how are the Ducks
and how are the Ducks getting a bar he's
got to be drinking down at the bar or
something like that and Star-Lord is
from Earth but I don't think we've I
don't think we've seen him go back to
Earth in all the time we've spent with
him yeah and all these other movies and
in present day there's gonna be a lot of
room to catch up with yeah I know I
think it's going to be one of those
movies that while it looks like really
funny and it's cool to see James Gunn
who's usually does even with guardians
uh he who can still bring that kind of
edgy sort of sense of humor uh that
James gun sort of associated with even
like Guardians 2 can explore some of
these more darker family themes and so I
wouldn't be surprised that if it
actually got a little bit serious by the
end and dealt with you know even if he
does go to Earth it happens to you know
maybe visit his mom's grave or whatever
like really go back to the roots of the
first Guardians movie like because as
much as this looks you know just some
type of you know intermission sort of
film for the Guardians just it's just a
holiday special it does feel like it's
going to be sort of integral for our
characters but especially Star-Lord out
of all them I know a lot of people
um myself included at times felt that
you know like characters like Drax and
mantis that they sort of just became
goofballs but I feel like the antics of
their type of back and forth are going
to feel like rewarded and paid off when
you put them in a genre movie like this
you know what I mean yeah I could
absolutely see that I feel like it it
creates a nice middle ground for both
opening up those characters back to the
real core of them the heartfelt parts of
them but also yeah like there's going to
be tons of situational comedy I think
that'll come out of hitting everyone
against Christmas time but I feel like
this is uh this could be a really fun
movie who knows who knows let's see what
happens let's see what happens alrighty
guys well thank you guys so much for
being here be sure to subscribe click
the notification Bell leave a like you
haven't seen a world with my night
reaction that's up here in the channel
we'll of course be covering this as well
last but not least
Mark Leach speaking of things that deal
with grief and loss and having to be
there with family and friends to help
pull you through I hope that when this
comes out that they can actually uplift
your spirits uh I feel like you know as
as tough as things have been for you as
of late won't go into anything too
personal right now obviously but as
tough as things have been for you as of
late uh and whenever I do get the chance
to talk with you it seems like that you
are doing the necessary steps of just
like persevering feeling your feelings
working your way through everything that
you got to work through and as much as
it can just seem like this real sort of
dark tunnel something that you can't
really get yourself out of the if
there's one thing I've learned with
aging is that you know the the phrase
about how you know things heal over time
they really do even if you can't see it
just from talking with you and knowing
everything that you're doing
it's it's already appearance as long as
you just sort of stay on that path
you've never once heard that If You're
Going Through Hell keep going because
eventually you'll get out you know
that's why they always say there's a lot
at the end of the tunnel there's these
cliches that exist but sometimes they're
more than cliches they exist for a
reason and they are very true and I
think everything you've been doing
lately is uh is is the right path to be
on so brother I hope that you're able to
uh Keep On Healing and I know especially
during the holidays um I myself included
from being totally honest uh can be
quite prone and sensitive and vulnerable
to emotions that uh obviously don't make
me feel the greatest I'm just one of
those uh you know uh winter sad people
so and I know with everything you've
been dealing with it can be even harsher
and so I I just want you to know that
just keep talking about it keep opening
up and then you know find some time to
be with as many people that you feel you
can just confide in so be well
foreign